Democrats plan to pay for much of their next
spending package by raising the tax burden
on corporations in the United States. Their
proposal would increase the corporate tax rate
from 21% to as much as 28%, and reform
the tax treatment of foreign profits of U.S.
multinational corporations. While raising the
corporate tax rate could generate significant
revenue for the federal government, it would reduce
the competitiveness of U.S. corporations and burden
working-class Americans. A superior policy, one
without the adverse economic consequences of a
corporate tax hike, is a carbon tax. A carbon
tax will raise energy prices to reflect the
environmental damage emissions cause, and as
consumers and producers work to avoid the tax
emissions will fall. A modest $15 per ton carbon tax
would raise as much revenue as President Biden's
corporate rate proposal. Moreover, it would drive
advancements and new investments in the energy
and transportation sectors. And it would negate
the need for costly and inefficient clean energy
tax credits, or regulations like Democrats' clean
electricity standard. Do you think Congress should
address the risks of climate change and impose a
price on carbon instead of raising the corporate
tax rate? Let us know in our poll. Also, let us
know what other topics you'd like our scholars
to cover in 60 seconds, and be sure to like and
subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.